[Music]
thank you for coming to see my
presentation I will be talking about
deep neural networks in social media
content analysis especially multimedia
where the deep neural networks excel at
yeah so let's start okay so why would we
even want to analyze social media
contents well I don't know about you but
for example I don't watch TV that's much
and so it happens more and often to me
that's when I hear about some news
that's happening is from social media
and it's actually a source main source
of information for more and more people
and it's not only about news but I don't
know there is everything social media
are becoming like a smaller Internet
where you can find everything and there
is this incredible amount of data that
we can analyze we have information about
we have many videos that's and we have
information about how many people
watched them and how they reacted to
them and we can use this this data to
analyze what users like what users want
to see what the users pay attention to
and especially with with videos we can
see that in social media sites like
Facebook they tend to go more viral and
have more views even if it is just I
know a recipe it can get over 300
million views so and we can perform this
kind of analysis that will be useful for
publishers like what to make videos
about what the users responds to better
so there's there's a good business value
here and today I will be talking about
three applications logo detection text
extraction and popularity prediction so
let's start with a logo detection so
first why would we want to
be doing such analysis well if you're a
brand owner you might want to know what
in what context your brand is visible so
if for example it is not factory of
cocaine in your factory of coca-cola you
want to want how much your logo is
exposed in what context is seen is it
positive or negative sentiment and maybe
where should should brand owners invest
to when they sponsor some events how
much this this brand is really visible
so I think it's worth investigating so
this is what our assumptions were we
shouldn't need a lot of data because
like nobody wants to spend time
annotating it our solution should be
able to detect even small logo types
because that's how they often appear and
should be fast because we want to apply
this analysis on videos so so we need to
often apply a detection frame-by-frame
so for this we used data sets that
consists of 32 classes has about 40
images per class so it's not a lot for
deep learning approaches but 4,000
background images and we implemented our
solutions in Kerris with ok so how can
we tackle this problem traditional
approach would be to train a classifier
that is able to distinguish image of a
logo type or a background for a fixed
size image and apply a sliding window to
to crop to provide with all the possible
locations where the image can appear but
of course this is very very inefficient
because we need to consider all the
possible locations or the aspect ratios
or the scales and this would be just
impractical to apply in practice so a
solution for this we can actually
perform this with convolution around
works much more efficiently usually in
neural net or Newton deep neural
networks applied to image you have a lot
of convolutional layers pulling layers
and in the end you have a fully
connected layers that take fixed input
size and output a fixed fixed size
output so that's why if you use fully
connected layers we need we need a fixed
input size image that would produce this
that will produce appropriate input for
a fully connected layer but actually we
can replace these fully connected layers
with convolutional layers that will do
exactly the same thing will be applied
to the feature map of the size that was
produced and this way we can run this
convolution operations on the image of
different sizes
and produce output feature output map
with scores for different logos that you
want to let that we want to detect and
interest this this is pretty simple
in case of convolution and connected
layers we have this dense dense layers
and we can just replace them with
convolutional layers that have filter
size of size that was the output of the
previous layer we also have to apply
softmax in this four dimensional because
we get this spatial scores so again this
is exactly what it looks like in
training time we still train for the
fixed size images but at this time
because we have this convolution layers
at the ends we can run it on image on
any size and as a result we will have a
bigger output that will provide us with
scores for different classes but in
different locations that's that's a good
way for efficient sliding window
implementation with convolution
never own networks so because we didn't
want to have a lot of data what we also
do is we use data augmentation and for
that we for background images we just
take random crops of migrant images that
we have that contain no logos for logo
images the way we do it we take random
crops of logos that that have this
intersection over Union so just this
common area of above 0.5 and this is an
example of how it works and this is done
online we don't we don't compute this
images and store it beforehand just when
when this images are needed for training
for another interation of training there
are generated in crisis just in simple
it by turn generator that can do that so
thanks to that it's very unlikely for
for the network to see exactly the same
example more than once
ok so our first attempt was to use
exactly what I just said just used 40
convolutional neural network we because
we didn't have a lot of data of course
we started with fine tuning fully con
natural network that was trained on
image net which I was the resident
architecture modified it to use only
convolutions so it's fully convolutional
as i said trained it on the fixed input
use the documentation applied crossing
minimize cross entropy loss as our
objective function and we got this so
this is not exactly what you wanted
because you wanted a very precise
location but so the although the
classification is good the location is
not what we wanted and this might be
partly because of this data augmentation
that we needed because we didn't have a
lot of data but it could have introduced
some problems with localization so our
solution for that
introducing bounding box regression and
the way this is done is so the part on
the left is common part of convolutional
neural network this produces some
feature maps on the on the top we have
this classification head which just also
something that was done before and now
we add this regression heads that also
based on the output of intermediate
layers of convolutional neural networks
provides four numbers that correct this
bounding boxes that would be produced by
just classification for a given for
given image and for that we also needed
to update our data argumentation to
provide not only with the images
augmented but also these four numbers
that are able to then correct the
correct precise location the bounding
box that will be produced so yeah but it
still wasn't enough because if we use
fully convolutional res Nets they are
this is a very big big network with many
parameters with a big input size about
it was 197 and 197 so if you want to
detect small logos that take that are
like 10% of an image we would need to
resize it first to 2,000 by 2,000 pixels
and it would be even slower so it turned
out to be quite impractical as well and
we can't prove another solution for that
we use the Cascade of networks so in
this case first we train a smaller
neural network that only provides with
proposals of where the logo type may
appear so it's it's a small network with
only a couple of layers not that many
parameters that will be not very precise
but we'll
limits the possible locations of where
the logo types might appear and and
we'll do it quickly because it's a small
network if small smaller input size then
after with the input output of this
first network we refine these proposals
with resonate strength similarly to
before but this now only evaluated
unfixed input size and so we can this
time we can train evaluate it providing
batches of images which will be also
much faster and and this resonance is
able to discriminate the proposals from
the background and properly logo types
and also this resonance in this case is
trained with hard negatives that is
negative proposals negative proposals
that had a high confidence score so it's
even more improves discriminability of
this network and this is an example of
like a real example where on the Left we
see the output of the our proposal
network that's predicted where a lot of
types might appear and on the right this
is after our second more powerful
network refined it ok so this is it for
a logo detection now let's move to text
extraction and again why would we want
to do that well it appears that many
many videos now on especially on
Facebook are designed to be watched on
mute but with subtitles and this is
because as I read recently that 85% of
Facebook videos are watched on mute so
the publishers they they chose to create
videos this way so that you can still
enjoy them I will consume them when you
end the bus on the subway and and get
the entire information and actually this
what makes it interesting to extract
this this text because this subtitles
often define the story about what is
happening in the video so if we could
have access to to this text we could
further analyze it with using NLP
techniques and know what the video was
about how users reacted to different
tags with different stories different
categories okay
so text extraction would consist of two
steps text detection in text recognition
in our experiments we used after initial
experiments we used text boxes as for
text detection which the texts were in
the image words are located and text
recognition which takes the image of the
world and outputs string what what this
reward is so those two work together
quite well so a couple of words how text
boxes work I didn't want to go into very
much details but they are based on SSD
object detector called a single-shot
detector and they perform classification
on outputs of which intermediate feature
maps that have different spatial
resolution and thanks to that we've just
one forward path they can predict where
they can detect the text immutable on
multiple scales and locations with just
one pass through the network and this is
the SSDs was done for object detection
and this is an approach that is adjusted
for text for this more horizontal mmm
that has more horizontal aspect ratio
and yeah and smallest for this are
available we this is most implemented by
the authors in cafe
and this is so we need to write Python
wrapper for to use it in our projects
which is quite easy we can initialize
the network with the provided models we
I usually like to wrap it in a single
class that can do it all we define a
transformation that will resize to the
input that this model requires transform
the image and forward to a forward pass
with the image the data okay and these
are some examples from the publication
of how it works you can see that it can
detect words quite well the red bounding
boxes are false positives in that appear
sometimes if there are some images that
resemble characters but it's in general
it looks it works quite good for the
text recognition we are using CR n n
which are convolutional recurrent neural
networks they are able to recognize
single words and with the pathogen
implementation and the way they work
they apply convolutional layers to the
image and the after several several
layers these fish from Alps are split as
feature sequences and fed to two
recurrent neural network that then
produces the predictions of what word it
is and we can just put it all together
use our text boxes for detection there
is intermittent cafe we can use our trnn
recognizer this is implemented in Python
and that way get the results that you
want for example the text crop the words
and running through the recognizer I
would wonder woman beats the sauce I
don't know
text extraction examples yen and these
are some examples on our data yeah it
seems to work quite okay and now we move
to popularity prediction so the question
is can we predict predict popularity of
a video from its visual features and
well we have a lot of data we have a
video we have information of how they
work on how they were consumed how many
people watched them and based on this
data we can try to predict whether the
video will be popular just using a
thumbnail or first seconds of the video
where often users make a decision
whether they are engaged or not and
apart from this analysis we can we can
make some we can draw some conclusions
of what users like what kind of
compositions what kind of topics are
attractive to users and this might be
important informations for publishers as
well how to create this how to create
these videos maybe how to select a
thumbnail what users respond to and the
way we approached it we had data set of
about 37,000 Facebook videos that were
published in a span of three months and
online for at least two weeks so that we
know that the number of views is more or
less settled and we can use thumbnails
or first seconds of the video because
that's actually how the way Facebook
counts views is if whether user watch it
after I think three seconds so we all
need to prepare the data we treat
popularity using we determine if the
video is popular by using number of
views we need to normalize this data
because of course different different
videos are posted on different pages
that have different number of likes so
there's there is advantage for
videos that have four videos to
represent on popular front pages so we
normalize the number of views by the
number of likes of fun on the fanpage
this problem can be seen as a regression
or classification but it's much easier
to solve as a classification so the way
we did it we just split the videos and
labeled them as popular or unpopular
based on the weather the number of views
is below or above the median value of
views and to train a model like that
we fine-tuned again convolution neural
network it was trained on image net we
use the resonate 15 network that is that
is easily easily applicable from cara's
and this is just a couple of lines of
code how easily we can do it we initiate
the resonant object with weights from
image net we said includes table to
false which means that it won't return
out this image and one thousand classes
but we'll just the features that we can
train the network on we can freeze the
layers that that were before and we
should do that if we don't have enough
enough data because if we don't our
network will probably overfeed quite
quickly and just add this last fully
connected layer that will provide us
with predictions in our case it would be
output two to two scores for whether the
image is popular or not and these are
some examples of best 100 videos that
our our algorithm found that are most
popular that were not in the training
set and the worst 100 videos and as we
can see most popular were videos with
food
and we can also see that that's all of
these videos have warmer colors on the
other hand there were 100 videos seem to
have seemed to be more about politics
it's their desire some kind of
interviews and the colors are colder is
an interesting observation another very
interesting thing that you can do is try
to visualize what the model what parts
of image contribute to popularity score
so here we have four examples on the
Left we have the raw image on the in the
middle we have a heat map of what parts
of in what part of image contributed to
popularity and on the right we have a
heat map what part of image contributed
to this court that it's unpopular and we
can see for example in here that nudity
of course of course makes the video more
popular which is not that surprising but
it's also can some kind of validation
that this model learned something useful
and and stuff like this some text rather
want wouldn't generate many clicks okay
so in conclusions I talked about local
detection for which we can use fully
convolutional neural networks and
cascade of networks to make it faster I
talked about text extraction where I
showed how what how we can use detection
and recognition to extract text from
videos and popularity prediction which
shows a way to train a classifier that
is able to predict whether the video is
popular or not and visualize how it made
its decision and if you're interested in
topics like that we are hiring and you
can check out our websites or drop me an
email and thank you
[Applause]
you